they're making me do it again my
producers have brought forth the crazies
of tick tock a place that is the home of
apparently an enormous amount of mental
anguish discontent it's just it's good
times all the time to take talk so let
the torture begin this video is brought
to you sadly by expressvpn why are we
still here just to suffer i'm cody
pronouns em air heirs or these enzosers
are really any neo-pronouns that aren't
z-hergers i am a white trans-masculine
fem non-binary temporarily mostly
able-bodied neurodivergent
obsessive-compulsive chronically ill
culturally jewish unitarian universalist
non-monogamous demi-lo romantic gray
demo bisexual survivor of acute and
complex trauma millennial and cat parent
in mental health recovery
[Music]
does she introduce herself that way at
parties sorry does emi or is is she
should she jurors introduce gyms
this way at parties i'm trying to do the
pronoun thing i'm having a tough time
okay so let's go through this list a
little bit you're temporarily mostly
able-bodied so like you what does that
mean like you stubbed your toe this
morning or what i'll have you know i
stubbed my toe last week and i only
cried for 20 minutes so some of these
things are actual medical like diagnoses
right obsessive compulsive disorder is
an actual medical diagnosis chronically
ill is sad culturally jewish i'm going
to go not smudge my culture is not a
costume non-monogamous
and uh demi low romantic demilo like you
like demi lovato yeah pansexual that's
hilarious
i got nothing cat parent was the thing
that explained it you don't need all the
rest cat parents my girlfriend and i
were talking about hypothetically if we
got married would you take my last name
obviously no we're feminists that's not
what we're trying to do but then i was
like okay so you're gonna keep
your mom your last name which is
actually that's that's actually your
dad's last name so you could take your
mom's last night but that's actually
her dad's last name
and
it go on and on it goes and i realized
there's no such thing
as a female
last name like they just simply don't
exist because
patriarchy okay so let me begin with i
think his girlfriend lives in canada she
goes to another school i don't believe
him that this is a conversation that
happened in real life as he talks about
being a feminist on his flamingo sheets
so i i don't believe him that he has a
girlfriend liar and the reason that the
woman generally took the father's name
is so the child would take the father's
name which was important because you can
establish the maternal lineage of a
child by the fact that the child was in
mom's body but it's harder to establish
the paternal lineage of a child without
the last name being applied to the kid
that's the actual reason why paternal
names became a thing patriarchy what do
you think is the number one contributing
factor to global warming
agriculture
the fashion industry
uh
something else
i'll tell you a secret it's the us
military
the us military is the world's largest
consumer of oil it's the world's biggest
polluter our armed forces create 750 000
tons of toxic waste
every year depleted uranium
jet fuel pesticides lead and other
chemicals too do you think it's a
coincidence that the military emissions
are often overlooked by climate studies
the kyoto protocol
that's why
there are actually very few things we
can do that are as environmentally
catastrophic as war
i think we all can see the irony that we
fight these wars in order to get oil
but if we didn't fight these wars
we wouldn't need the oil
not as much
uh
i will admit to you
that watching this person spastically
dance while uttering noam chomsky
talking points is almost hypnotically
bad it is almost hypnotic i would watch
like a full hour of that would you not
come on come on be honest watching this
person gyrate like vincent d'onofrio
having their body occupied by an alien
while explaining silliness about how we
fight wars for oil which is strange
because we didn't take any of the oil
from iraq i was amused by that i will
admit i i found that wildly entertaining
i'm big fan of that one
uh oh okay here we go here's an abortion
one life doesn't begin at conception
when does it begin it doesn't matter
brandon it's never mattered at no point
ever has it mattered whether it's just a
clump of cells or a fully fledged person
already accepted to harvard university
it has never ever mattered
when life begins the point is that a
person cannot use another person's body
without their permission by forcing
women to share their bodies with fetuses
to keep them alive you are actually
suggesting that fetuses should have more
rights than any other person in the
world and that people with uteruses
should have less rights if you want a
fetus to have the same rights as other
people i hate to break it to you but you
be pro-choice um okay so question how
did the baby get in there
did the baby just randomly attach itself
to you this actually is a fairly
frequent example that's brought up by
the philosopher judith thompson she
suggests the the quote-unquote famous
violinist problem okay the famous
violinist problem is a famous violinist
is hit by a bus and you are sedated and
when you awake the famous violinist is
linked to you by an iv that is keeping
them alive are you allowed to pull out
the iv he said there are a few problems
with this one the famous violinist is
not your child if the famous violinist
for your child pretty strong moral case
no and that does change based on the
relationship with the child too what if
you took the action that led to the
person being linked to you which is
generally the case in abortion right
leading aside rape or incest in the vast
majority of cases people who get
pregnant do so because they took a
voluntary action that led to the
pregnancy that is a predictable risk of
having sex regardless of whether you're
using birth control you know the risk
that you are going to end up being
impregnated that young man is how babies
are made the question is not even
whether you should decouple
the baby from the uterus in most of
these cases in most of these cases
you're talking about violent act so if
you have the violinist problem where you
are linked via iv with the person there
is even a difference morally between you
plucking the iv out of your arm and you
getting up and stabbing the person in
the head dismembering them and flushing
them down the toilet
[Applause]
we'll get to more of this torture but
first using the internet without
expressvpn it's like walking your dog in
public without securing the dog on a
leash most of the time you'll probably
be fine but what if one day your dog
wanders a bit too far and gets
dog-napped by somebody from tick-tock
everybody needs a vpn to protect your
online activity it's very very important
because here's the thing every time you
connect to an unencrypted network cafes
hotels airports etc your online data is
not secure any hacker on the same
network can gain access to and steal
your personal data we're talking like
passwords financial details etc hackers
can make up to one thousand dollars per
person selling personal information on
the dark web why is expressvpn because
it's great they create a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so hackers can't steal your
sensitive data but take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years to
get past express vpn's encryption it
works on all of your devices your phones
laptops tablets and more you can stay
secure wherever you are fire up that app
you click one button and it gets
protected let me show you how it works
right so here i go i open my expressvpn
app it says not connected okay boink
connected protected expressvpn is just
that easy the ease of use the protection
that is what i am seeking from my vpn
you should do the same secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com and that's expressvpn.com
you can get an extra three months for
free expressvpn.com
so i'm driving home from a chiropractor
appointment i never actually had it
because i left
because
here's the deal i show up i'm in the
parking lot call them up oh you don't
have to call us ahead of time
okay so i go in no signs up about masks
no one's wearing masks
i got mine on but
okay
but then i see it
an advertisement for somebody running
for the local school board taped to the
reception desk so everybody can see it
bullet points are constitutional rights
freedom of choice blah blah blah
taped to the desk at a reception of a
freaking doctor's office
i mean okay chiropractor they're not
really doctors but still what the hell
why am i why
why do i have to make the decision to
leave the office because you are
an idiot
i am so tired of this
you stop don't come back my
favorite thing is that he's super pissed
off that it says things like there's for
a candidate and it says constitutional
rights on there and i had to leave i
hate the constitution
that was the most offensive thing on the
poster
really like that's what drove you out of
the out of the office interesting but
you know what he exercised his his
business judgment and left and i'm sure
there will be somebody else who is
willing to take his space
i am wearing the pants
he's wearing the skirt
we're both gay
he's pregnant i have two girlfriends
it's 20 21. okay this is like a really
up algebra problem i'm gonna need
that again
i'm wearing the pants
he's wearing the skirt
we're both gay
he's pregnant okay stop that's the
giveaway person in the purple hair is a
woman he is not a he he's a woman how do
i know cause women are the ones who get
pregnant oh man you can't say that so
here you have a woman who is saying that
she is wearing pants which many women do
and he meaning she is wearing a skirt
she is gay the other one is also gay so
that sort of begs the question as to how
the pregnancy occurred i assume through
some well i mean i'm not going to make
any assumptions not from her i mean
clearly she has two other girlfriends
but this isn't one of them because she's
designating this one a he so she has
three girlfriends but one of them calls
herself a man i understand everything
now so if the question was how many
women are in this equation the answer is
four
if the question is how long until our
civilization collapses the answer is
zero yeah i
no can no
no
can't know
hello lovelies
i just want to talk about people
misgendering um
it's okay if you misgender me
just make sure you don't put your hands
on me
or you might get hurt good
i mean honestly like more power to this
human male hey now good seriously good
can this be our standard from now on
like this seems like a natural tolerant
transgender person right i mean like if
you misgender me you make a mistake and
you offend me or use a biological
pronoun which is not actually
misgendering that's just using actual
normal human language the way it's
typically used if you do that as long as
you don't actually put your hands on me
i'm good this is like one of the more
sane people we're seeing on tick tock
right there
that was horrifying in every conceivable
way we are all stupider for having
watched it i hope that you enjoyed that
more than i did experiencing it in real
time i feel as though each time we do
one of these videos the number of brain
cells in my head decreases and it's it's
exponentially increasing so i'm not sure
how many more of these we can crank out
before i lose full brain function and
end up babbling into my gruel like the
president of the united states but oh he
thinks he's running i'll keep bringing
them to you
if you keep watching them
they'll continue torturing me that's
pretty much the calculus here so leave a
comment below like
subscribe if you wish to see my
producers continue to subject me to
cruel and unusual punishment from tick
tock